[MUSIC PLAYING]
GLEN KEANE: Good morning.
Thanks for making it here
early in the morning.
You, know, looking at some of
those pictures of me years ago,
I noticed something that
was kind of missing now.
Yeah.
All these characters
I've been animating--
Pocahontas and
Rapunzel-- it's like I'm
making up for the lack
of something in my life.
I'm not sure what that would be.
But I've got this strange
belief that the characters
that I've animated,
created, designed
exist before I draw them.
And that was the case with the
Beast, which I'll show you.
I didn't know what the Beast
was going to look like,
and my assistant, who is
standing just like where Jason
is-- he didn't have a camera--
but he said, so what's the
Beast going to like look like?
I don't know.
It's going to--
I kind of like this
buffalo-like like head shape.
There's kind of a
sadness to the buffalo.
And I had the buffalo
head on my wall.
Maybe that's why it looked sad.
I don't know.
But there's this bear-like
body and the crest
of a gorilla's head, and
a gorilla expressive brow
like that.
And as I was explaining
to my assistant,
it's like, I like the
muzzle of a wild boar
with the hair coming back, and
these tusks that are coming up,
and the beard
though of a buffalo.
But Belle's got to hug
him, so let's give him
this mane like a lion there.
And the horns-- and
I've been studying
a lot of different
horns, and they'll
be like a combination
of these horns.
And it was just like this.
I was drawing it, just kind
of feeling it out like that.
And then I started
thinking, but wait a second.
Belle's not going to fall
in love with this guy.
This isn't going to work.
Nobody is going to believe this.
I'll give him cow ears.
That'll make him a little
friendlier, like that.
But inside-- there's a
prince trapped inside,
and the eyes are the
window to the soul.
And so you can see
the prince looking out
from inside this
body of this beast.
And as I drew him
I said, that's him.
There he is.
I mean, just as long as it took
me just now to draw it for you,
it did that day, and
Beast suddenly appeared.
And that's kind of the
magic of creativity.
I think the key to it is
thinking like a child.
There's something wonderful--
this is my granddaughter
Matisse and she's drawing there.
The secret to her drawing is
either in that bottle of milk
or the glass of Merlot,
I'm not quite sure.
But there was this little
six-year-old girl, and she--
she said to her dad, Daddy,
where do you go all day?
And he was a professor of
drawing at a university.
He said, well, sweetheart, I
teach big people how to draw.
And she said, oh,
you mean they forget?
Picasso said, when I was
young, I could draw and paint
like Raphael.
But it's taken me a lifetime
to learn to draw like a child.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
If you watch him draw, it's
a pretty wonderful thing.
It's not rushed.
It's as if he's having
a conversation with what
he's making.
He's listening to it.
It says, over here,
and he responds.
It's not a one-way thing.
[END PLAYBACK]
I think this is how--
whether you are writing
music, writing code, painting,
drawing, whatever--
it's a conversation
you are having with
what you are making.
You have to be open to it.
And drawing is a really
interesting thing.
If you ask yourself,
so what is drawing?
If you hold a pencil, a pencil
is an amazing little tool.
It's what I would say is--
simplicity is the
ultimate sophistication.
You hold it.
It makes a mark at
this end, and there's
a line that goes straight
down my arm to my heart,
where what I feel, what I
see, I can communicate to you.
You can't see it.
It's hidden inside of me.
And for whatever it
is that you're doing,
we all have something
inside of us
that we are wanting to
touch other people with.
We're wanting to
communicate it somehow.
And the tools that we use
to express that hidden thing
are incredibly important.
But this is really simple,
and the simplicity--
the clarity-- that the tool
can communicate what is hidden
is really, really important.
If you look at my
drawings, my drawings
look like that when
I first animate.
I mean, I think of drawing
as a seismograph of my soul.
It's like the line.
It's just this explosion.
So first I draw like this,
and then it becomes like that
as I tie it down.
But it first started as
that rough explosion.
And I want to show this little
clip from "The Little Mermaid,"
and it's back from the '80s.
So it's ancient
technology on video,
and it's the pencil version
of "Part of Your World."
It's just a little bit.
But there's this one
part where Ariel--
longing to be up on
the surface and not
be down under the water, and
she wants more than anything
to be part of that world--
and I was a 33-year-old
guy, and I'm
being a 16-year-old mermaid.
And at a certain
point, I realized
Ariel wants to swim up
straight to the camera, looking
at the audience, and reach
out and then drift back down,
and I started getting
kind of nervous,
like this is really cheesy.
Everybody's going to know
how sentimental I am.
And I was like, I can't do that.
But I couldn't stop Ariel.
She did it anyway.
So take a look at this
little clip of animation.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC - JODI BENSON, "PART OF
YOUR WORLD"]
[END PLAYBACK]
Years after I'd animated that--
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So years after I
animated that, I
was speaking at Cal Arts, the
animation department there,
and one of the students came
up to me and said, Mr. Keane,
there is this animation
from "The Little Mermaid,"
and it's in "Part
of Your World,"
where Ariel reaches out.
I don't know if you remember it.
And I said, no, no.
I remember that.
Yeah.
Well, I was four years old,
and I was in the movie theater,
and as Ariel was
reaching out, I stood up
in the middle of the theater
and reached my hands out
to take her hands because she
wanted to be part of my world.
And I said, thank you.
Thank you.
See, because the thing
is, that thing that
makes us us, as I
was feeling funny,
like I didn't want to
do that, because I felt
like I was exposing myself--
I was being vulnerable--
and that part of
us that is hidden,
that's the very thing that
you have to put out there.
The thing that you think
you're the only one that
feels that way--
that's what you have
to go out and say.
The thing that makes you
kind of uncomfortable,
like, what would
people think of me--
that's the thing that you
need to do in whatever field
you are in.
One point.
Ollie Johnston, one of
the mentors at Disney--
he had done "Pinocchio"
and "Snow White,"
and many of these films--
he said, Glen, you're going
to do greater things than us
someday.
And I was like, oh, I
wish he'd never said that.
Like, I mean, how are you going
to do greater than "Pinocchio"
or "Bambi" or "Fantasia"?
And I carried that around
with me for many years.
And after about 40
years at Disney,
I felt like something
new was calling to me,
and I didn't know what it was.
Behind my house,
there was this field,
and I took this picture
of that little trail,
because I felt like that's my
feeling right now that there's
something beyond that
I can't see what it is.
But what am I going to do?
I've been there 40 years.
This is like, this is my life.
How can I take that step?
My wife saw how I was feeling.
She said, well, what would you
do if you weren't at Disney?
Where would you go?
I said, I don't know.
Google?
She said, Google?
They don't do animation.
I know, but wouldn't it be
cool if you took animation
to someplace that
they don't do that?
And I read this quote.
"Until one is committed,
there is hesitancy,
the chance to draw back--
concerning all acts of
initiative and creation,
there is one elementary truth--
that the moment one
definitely commits oneself,
then Providence moves too.
A whole stream of events
issues from the decision, which
no man could have dreamed
would have come his way.
Whatever you can do, or
dream you can do, begin it.
Boldness has genius,
power, and magic in it.
Begin it now."
So I left, and the first
thing that happened
was Google called.
And we came up here,
and it's just amazing
how something like that
would seem so impossible
suddenly was because
I took that step.
And we were working with
Regina Dugan at ATAP,
and they had this new technology
where you could animate and see
your animation on a
phone, and there's
no limit to what you were doing.
And it was at 60 frames
per second, not 24,
and we did this little
film "duet," a story
about two little babies--
a little boy and a little girl--
and they keep crossing paths
and it's a circular story
as they grow up, and you
can follow one or the other.
Regina described it as
like a double helix.
Instead of a linear story, it
was like two spiral staircases.
And I was thinking, this is--
I've never done this before.
Picasso said, I'm always
doing that which I cannot do,
in order that I may
learn how to do it.
It's such an important
truth for us to get.
Not knowing how to do something
is a great reason to do it.
Well, what's really important
is the intention-- the desire.
Do you have a desire
to do something?
Do you do want to
accomplish something,
but you don't know how?
You've already got the
most important part,
which is the desire.
It's about taking that
step, and everything
starts coming together.
When we came up here to
Google to do this animation,
I had no idea, but
found in working
with this wonderful
group of programmers--
folks that were just as
creative in their field
as I was in mine--
we started to work
together at night.
I would teach them
figure drawing,
and then they would teach
me about algorithms.
And we did this
little film "duet,"
which I'll show you a
little piece of here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This is the theatrical
version that--
you really-- on the phone,
you can watch the characters
go any direction.
But this, we had to cut it
so it works in the theater.
[END PLAYBACK]
So you can see the rest
of it and download the app
on Spotlight Stories.
By the time Kobe
called and asked
if I would animate a letter that
he wrote to basketball called
"Dear Basketball," I realized
that what Ollie Johnson had
said to me, that you're going
to do greater things than us
someday, I was wrong about
that, that he wasn't talking
about greater in quality.
He was talking about
greater in application.
To take the things
that you learned
and apply it in places and
ways that Ollie and those nine
old men never could
have imagined.
And here was Kobe inviting me
now into NBA to do basketball.
I told Kobe.
I said, look, you've
got the worst basketball
player on Earth animating you.
He said, no, that's good.
That way, everything you
learn about basketball
is going to be
through studying him.
And it was.
So he wrote this letter,
really from the point of view
of a six-year-old thanking
basketball for giving him--
this little six-year-old boy--
his Laker dream.
And I think that this
is a wonderful truth
that that six-year-old version
of you is still with you now.
We all have that
six-year-old kid
that had something to do with
why you are sitting here today,
and who you are, and
what you are doing.
That six-year-old--
that child that
has that spark of
creativity that
is that essential
thing-- is still there,
but sometimes we
become so professional.
We become so good at
what we do, we forget.
We forget who we are--
that little six-year-old.
So listening to Kobe talk--
I have a little clip here
where Kobe is talking about
hand-drawn, and John Williams,
who did the music for it,
who's talking about
thinking like a child,
and it's this wonderful
blend of these things that--
take a listen here to
Kobe and John's talk.
Apparently, Kobe can call
anybody in the universe
and get him to work on his film,
because he got John Williams
to do the music for us.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
KOBE BRYANT: I think
there has to be a level
of hand-drawn touch to it.
You know, it has
more texture to it.
It has more soul to it.
JOHN WILLIAMS: It's so
personal, this thing.
Leonard Bernstein used to
always talk about music
and inspiration, and he
would reference the idea that
an artist should be always in
touch with his childish self--
the first eight years before you
really understood what was up
and down--
a sense of magic and
a sense of discovery--
when you reinterpret a piece of
music, or you conduct, or sing,
or whatever--
KOBE BRYANT: The blank canvas.
JOHN WILLIAMS: To bring that
kind of openness and exposure
of yourself to the audiences is
the thing that as we get older,
we forget how to do.
[END PLAYBACK]
GLEN KEANE: When we get
older, we forget how to do.
Here's this guy
who's 86 years old,
and he's talking about
hanging on to that thing.
Don't forget.
Don't forget that
part of the adventure
that you have as a child--
the scary part, like I
don't know how to do this.
That's OK.
Maybe that's what
you really need.
There's this element of
fear that that's always
keeping you on the edge.
I always felt like the one
thing we all have in common
is that if anybody knew
how much we're faking it,
we'd all get booted out of here.
That's how I've always
felt my whole career.
So I want to show you
"Dear Basketball."
The themes of this child
being still part of you
as an accomplished
professional are really
what the message
is underneath this.
This could be called Dear
whatever the field is--
Dear Programming, Dear
Architecture, Dear Basketball,
Dear Animation.
Let's take a look.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: A one-point game.
[SQUEAKING AND THUDDING]
SPEAKER 1: Bryant, for the win!
[BUZZING]
KOBE BRYANT: Dear Basketball.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
From the moment I started
rolling my dad's tube socks
and shooting imaginary
game-winning shots in the Great
Western Forum, I knew
one thing was real.
I fell in love with you--
a love so deep I
gave you my all,
from my mind and body
to my spirit and soul.
As a six-year-old boy
deeply in love with you,
I never saw the
end of the tunnel.
I only saw myself
running out of one.
And so I ran.
I ran up and down every court
after every loose ball for you.
You asked for my hustle.
I gave you my heart because
it came with so much more.
I played for the
sweat and the hurt.
Not because challenge called me.
But because you called me.
I did everything for
you, because that's
what you do when someone makes
you feel as alive as you've
made me feel.
You gave a six-year-old
boy his Laker dream.
And I'll always love you for it.
But I can't love you
obsessively for much longer.
This season is all
I have left to give.
My heart can take the pounding.
My mind can handle the grind.
But my body knows it's
time to say goodbye.
And that's OK.
I'm ready to let you go.
I want you to know now, so we
both can savor every moment
we have left together--
the good and the bad.
We have given each
other all that we have.
And we both know no
matter what I do next,
I'll always be that kid
with the rolled-up socks,
the garbage can in the corner,
five seconds on the clock,
ball in my hands.
Five, four, three, two, one.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
Love you always, Kobe.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
GLEN KEANE: Thank you.
That was a lot of fun.
I knew nothing about
basketball, but I've
got to say, after I animated it,
I'd been studying Kobe's jump
shot, and one night on
the Lakers training court,
I got out there and grabbed
one of the basketballs,
and I thought, I'm
going to do this.
I know how to do it.
It's like, there's-- you throw--
you jump up and
you're leaning back.
You've got your left
hip out a little bit.
Your right hip is back, and
then you get a 90-degree angle
with your hand.
I studied it all.
I knew it.
And I jumped up and phew--
from way out, a three-pointer,
and the ball's just like,
I couldn't believe it-- it was
just straight for the basket,
and it fell 10 feet short, but--
but for a moment,
it was so cool.
So I want to leave
you with this term--
sprezzatura.
It's a word that was
coined about 500 years ago,
and it was used to describe the
difference between Michelangelo
and Raphael.
This is an art critic, and
he saw that Michelangelo had
such a knowledge of anatomy.
It was all out.
It was on the outside.
You could see all the muscles
and the structure, and--
whereas Rafael, who knew the
same anatomy as Michelangelo,
it was all hidden, as he would
paint "Madonna and Child," it
was very smooth forms and--
And so he came up with
this term, sprezzatura.
That means art
that hides its art.
It's really the art
of becoming invisible.
And I thought,
wow, this is really
a pretty wonderful thing.
It means that taking that
invisible thing inside of you
and make it can become visible--
the better you are
at taking that thing
and making it become
visible, the more visible
it becomes and the
more invisible you are.
And that's the goal.
It's not about you.
It's about the thing
that you're making.
It's about you
touching somebody else.
And I don't think I really
understood that until one day
at Disneyland.
I was going to--
I have a Silver pass, so I
can get in anytime I want.
It comes after 40
years at Disney.
So my wife had family
and friends come out
from Minnesota, and we were
walking up to Disneyland,
and there's a big line of
people to get into the park,
and our friends got in
the back of the line.
And I said, no.
Come on.
Follow me.
So we walk up to the
front of the line,
and I pull out my
wallet, and I realize
I forgot my Silver pass.
I can't get in without--
so I said, look.
Excuse me.
I have a Silver pass,
but I left it at home.
The guy said, sorry,
you can't get in.
I said, yeah, well.
Look.
Can you just look it
up on your computer?
Here's my Disney ID.
And he said, nope.
Sorry.
Can't do that.
And our family and
friends are coming around.
What's the problem?
I said, no, no.
It's all right.
And this voice in my head
is saying, don't do this.
But I couldn't not.
And I said, look, did
you see "Aladdin?"
The guy says-- he
didn't say anything.
He just kind of looked at me.
I did that.
That design of that
character, that was me.
No reaction.
I said, well, did you
see "The Little Mermaid?"
Still like this skeptical look.
And I said, that was me.
I designed and animated Ariel.
Still no reaction.
And then I said, well, did
you-- and before I could even
get the third one out he said,
look, I don't care who you are.
You're going to get in the
back of the line like everybody
else.
There's all the family
and friends around there,
and I said, I guess we've got
to go in the back of the line.
And they're all
following me, kind
of like, yeah, Glen, big deal.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
They were really enjoying it.
I was furious.
Got in line, got
up to the front,
bought the tickets from
the guy-- thank you--
and then went into the
park, and I was just, oh!
OK.
You guys go on a ride.
I'm just going to have to--
I've got to cool off.
So I sat on the bench--
the Disney park bench there--
and along comes the Beast--
the park Beast.
Boom, ba-dum,
boom, ba-dum, boom.
And he stops, and
he looks towards me,
and he comes walking
straight towards me,
and he sits on the
bench next to me.
So it's me and the Beast.
I say, hi, Beast.
I'm thinking, isn't this ironic?
I designed you.
I can't even get into the park.
It's just like, oh.
And then I hear
this little girl.
Beast!
And she comes running up--
running straight up to Beast--
and jumps up onto his lap,
hugs him, and starts
kissing his tusks.
I mean, the very tusks
that as I was drawing them,
I was remembering,
I was thinking,
Belle's never going to
fall in love with this guy.
Here's this little girl
just loving the Beast.
I didn't even understand
that lesson of beauty
is only skin deep, you know.
I didn't understand
it, but now I
did, and here's this little
girl believing in the Beast.
I never felt so invisible and
just so happy to be invisible.
Beast was real, and that
little girl saw him that way.
And the rest of the
day at the park, I
had the best day
of my life there.
It was wonderful.
And I think this is the thing.
It's taking that
thing inside of us,
translating it so you can see
it, to touch somebody else.
I'd like to finish
with just this one
drawing, except it's
bringing technology
into a new way of drawing.
For me, I've never seen drawing
as just a flat piece of paper.
I've always imagined it
as sculptural drawing,
dimensional drawing.
I think of it that way.
So Google has this
wonderful tilt
brush that allows me to
draw in virtual reality,
and this is really the way
I see it in my head anyway,
that you don't see it
this way, but I do.
Thank you, Elmer.
OK.
And hopefully, I don't
fall off into the people
in the front row there.
OK.
Maestro.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
JODI BENSON: Maybe he's right.
Maybe there is something
the matter with me.
I just don't see
how a world that
makes such wonderful
things could be bad.
[MUSIC - JODI BENSON, "PART OF
YOUR WORLD"]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
GLEN KEANE: Thank you.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]